[Music]
rejects I'm Gregg John as me rejects
that's an insulting intro but
complimentary when you're here cuz we're
joining us
topper war tier patron video request is
from no hit menergy Assassin's Creed 3
III official trailer
he likes to request game trailers for
games I came out forever ago yeah but
they're often the cinematic ones and
ones that we have not seen so if people
requesting them we've already seen we
just tell him we were decide but I want
to read his message here he says I've
seen you guys react to many of the
recent assassin creed trailers
especially Assassin's Creed unity was
one of the first reaction I saw of you
guys I remember that this franchise is
one of the current generations gaming
series which became too big too fast and
builds a really dedicated fanbase but
now just another franchise churning out
almost yearly installments reminds me of
Mario back in the day they started off
well with really good storylines with
the recent ones just sort of going
downhill hey you're not the only one who
I've heard nevertheless the trailers the
games are often really well crafted that
this specific one reminds me of John
wakin away the whole one-man army kind
of idea all you needed was that last
line nothing else let's watch this maybe
18
now you be so
very good thanks man
I watched him fight and die in the name
of freedom
they speak of liberty injustice but for
whom I'm an American
[Music]
hours
[Music]
whoa
nice
[Music]
[Music]
yeah um
[Music]
the lobster backs
[Music]
whoa
whoa
[Music]
George
[Music]
that's how we won
[Music]
it's pretty cool
that was cool nothing says Halloween
like the American Revolution not a movie
like that where there's a like an army
and a whole battlefield of people like
they're shooting and that one guy just
steps in and jacks up the enemy have
they done that yet
you know Wonder Woman I guess but she's
like super extra superhuman you know
just some like warrior you know going in
there and just slicing and dicing I'm
sure there is man I mean what's rising
like I'm sure that it exists comment
below recommend us a movie how old is
this game the graphics don't look really
great yeah I know this said it was 2012
who said it was supposed to come out
hallelujah no sounds like what 15 years
ago yeah 15 years ago to this day of
recording this wow that's crazy yeah we
have aged well you have aged terribly
have aged teeny get some sleep that's
what I say Oh buddy but yeah I'm always
fascinated when they set video games and
like really historic times that you
don't like I feel like the revolution is
not one it's like World War one there's
not as much revolution stuff as there is
Civil War stuff there's not as much
World War one stuff as there's World War
two stuff and like to take a video game
and set it in the revolution seems kind
of fascinating to me just aesthetically
this is not where you're used to being
this was cool because it is
anachronistic but I didn't have as much
of that Public Enemies Syndrome where
I'm like this is really distracting you
know Akron is stick anachronistic is
when like an anachronism is something
like an element included somewhere that
is out of sync with the time period or
something like that it's like if you see
a movie set in the 70s but there's an
80s car that's an anachronism because it
wouldn't have existed at that time or it
doesn't match with the time time you
know the construct man the flat circle
that we all conform to to get by and be
basic sheeple on this planet Earth
Society that we made here breath here
here the
the place that we occupy presently the
place that can always be just assigned
to where you find yourself at any given
moment here
Oh often marked by red arrows on
directories at the mall ah
uh-huh I know what a mall is I go to the
food okay yeah it's exactly how it
sounds do I need to explain it to you
geez are you stupid
okay so like you know the law there's a
judge bailiff and everything and then we
debate about who's food is guilty no I
can't go gonna stick lemonade
okay and then there's Chinese food next
to it okay there's a tallying interface
so it's like the Olympics there's like
every country sends some get you to the
food court and then they don't get out
you know it's like a Dunkin Donuts yeah
yeah yeah it's a great bit it's
interesting to hear this series
described as something that got too big
too fast because being an outsider at
least into the nitty-gritty of gaming I
can kind of get that sense because it
feels like it's been a while since
people really got excited about
Assassin's Creed and I almost I was not
an event anymore man it's just another
episode to be coming out or an
assassin's creed which is a bummer
because I remember this is one of the
most talked about games in it first came
out I know when you play it I did yeah I
had assasin creed to actually I had the
one where you were in old-time Rome well
that Michael Fassbender movie just
ruined everything I feel like that was
perhaps the solidify er of the state of
the franchise when you're finally big
enough to have your own drab and
uninspired blockbuster I love the way
people battled back then in these wars
where they were all lined up take turns
shooting each other
yeah and spend like 15 minutes like
reloading and like go to the front I
want to go to the front I go there you
go front oh my god I'm gonna shower I've
been waiting for them to shoot it gets
shot with a really an efficient
projectile that's probably gonna stick
in my skin for years and get infected if
I don't die or have something amputate
or bled and purpose who came up with the
rules of war back then who said that
this is the way it should be all right
look if we're gonna go to war we got to
have some rules the word take turns
shooting the front of the lodge before
we charge at each other yeah yeah before
we resort to bayonets we gotta at least
do it from a distance because yeah maybe
we didn't need it so close I don't like
you you don't like me with let's do this
room far away as we can
nah man this is great stuff George
Washington was there going I know that
guy Ted did he I don't know the
storyline of this what's this
description you were a Conner warrior
son of a Native American mother and
British father his colonies draw closer
to revolution you will become the spark
the all spark that ignites the
revolution into a full blaze Wow Wow man
dude almost as if he's a warrior named
Conor destined to help and the
revolution and for us to win can't think
of another character with that name it
seems weird I don't know what the story
you'll see though I kind of strange that
a son of a Native American would then be
fighting to help the Americans why we
were or the premonition at all really
didn't we get anyone involved with this
didn't we like help like the Native
Americans were bored and then we came
here and we solved all the problems like
man we got nothing to do why don't you
make us fight for our lives land crops
and everything else that we hold my
Native Americans celebrate Thanksgiving
I think you're too good here we need to
feel some real adversity and struggle
they were born man-toe you're like you
know we need gold needed yeah that's
what's truly important either way to
screw the sustainable land and this you
know agriculture we got and our hunting
practices I mean that's why when hot
chicks go to Coachella they would hurt
you were like together headdresses and
stuff like that and they appropriate
that guy understand it appreciated to
the utmost degree exactly so this only
makes sense to me yeah what a name the
Native American guy would
oh yeah when this trailer was directed
by Mel Gibson so you know that makes a
little whatsit yeah uh-huh he was like
man I'm just I'm not done after the
Patriot I just need one more taste and
then 2012 rolls around and they're like
we need a trailer for our American
Revolution sci-fi action videos well Oh
hit I'm sure you appreciated this video
so much insight I think we gave the best
insight to franchise we did we're so
good at this frigging gamers all right
but you watch every movie watcher ratio
game I literally do something
I spend no time with other people the
only time I see people I'm either
watching stuff for playing games
well guys go check out the hit
Banerjee's channel he's got some great
short films over there congratulations
on the move he just moved in with a few
people hot they're all hot men Oh
fortunately lo hit is a firely
homosexual firely homosexual yeah I'm
just as good with the words as John is
you still have someone to want that day
I was saying flaming about like his
flamin insulting I don't I don't is it
insulting if you don't know it's insult
anyway you're not as morally culpable
culpable is when you have a certain
responsibility for your own actions and
you know it implies that you knew what
you were doing
why didn't you just say that I'm sorry I
just need to stop using all these
five-dollar words you guys subscribe to
the real rejects good been notification
Mel if you happen to like this video to
like but don't why you love this
now let's check you guys out soon